Fox News leaked text messages confirm
that while on air people like Sean
Hannity Tucker Carlson and Laura
Ingraham were acting as though there was
Merit and legitimacy to Donald Trump's
bogus claims that he actually won the
2020 election privately Fox hosts were
texting each other and others and saying
this is nonsense we know it's nonsense
this is a really big disaster
fascinating but not altogether
surprising story Rolling Stone has an
article
Tucker Carlson pushes election fraud
BS same night filing reveals he knows
it's BS
Dominion voting systems is suing Fox
News for spreading conspiracy theories
conspiracies about the company's role in
non-existent fraud in the 2020 election
Dominion submitted a bombshell legal
filing Thursday revealing that most of
the Fox News hosts who pushed the big
lie knew it was total BS as well as the
internal strife over how to cover it
these text messages are fascinating
Tucker Carlson was particularly incensed
the filing reveals quote Sidney Powell
is lying by the way I caught her it's
insane he texted to Laura Ingraham on
November 18th
Ingraham responded that Sydney Powell is
quote a complete nut as is Rudy Giuliani
quote it's unbelievably offensive to me
said Carlson our viewers are good people
and they believe it well then why are
you continuing to push that idea
on air he said how did senile hermit Joe
Biden get 15 million more votes than his
boss Rockstar crowd Surfer Barack Obama
results like that would seem to defy the
laws of known physics and qualify
instead as a miracle was the 2020
election a miracle Obama
um so what so the the story here is they
knew it was BS they were texting each
other that it was BS and yet on air they
continued to entertain this stuff as if
it was a serious thing here's an example
of Laura Ingram interviewing Sydney
Powell whom privately she was saying is
a complete nut
five
point I really need to get after it
right now right now
reports of fraud there are hundreds of
them wow hundreds of report of fraud
reports of fraud that's that's stunning
huh well I hope uh attorney general Barr
is doing that
um very very hopeful that he's doing
that otherwise we're in big trouble as a
country especially with elections going
forward yeah so there's understand
privately Laura Ingram is saying Sydney
Powell is a nut okay publicly Sydney
Powell comes on makes all of these false
claims about the election and Laura
Ingram says if this isn't being
investigated we're in trouble as a
country wow
openly lying to their audience
another example here's actually a good
little compilation that CNN did remember
privately all of these people all of
these people are saying this is nonsense
here's what they were saying publicly
the fix already in it is is a damning
indictment of Fox News the outcome of
our presidential election was seized
from the hands of Voters as a network
publicly and repeatedly promoted former
president Trump's 2020 election fraud
claims to millions of their viewers
every American should be angry you
should be outraged you should be worried
you should be concerned at what has
happened in the election in the lead-up
to this election and privately top
anchors and Executives mocked Trump's
lies calling them ludicrous really crazy
stuff and totally off the rails the
revelations coming from hundreds of
pages of newly released evidence in the
legal filing as part of the Dominion
voting system's lawsuit against Fox News
in this text exchange two weeks after
the election Tucker Carlson texting
other Fox News hosts Sydney Powell is
lying by the way I caught her it's
insane he says about Trump's lawyer
Sydney Powell and Rudy giuliani's
unfounded claims Sydney is a complete
nut no one will work with her did with
Rudy Laura Ingram wrote back Tucker
responds it's unbelievably offensive to
me our viewers are good people and they
believe it even as those same hosts went
on the air arguing completely otherwise
all right these election challenges are
still going on and disturbing
irregularities have been found and must
be investigated have they really Laura
made it to the fullest on Election night
the network first to call Arizona for
Biden the Fox News decision desk is
calling Arizona for Joe Biden that is a
big get for the Biden campaign as
Trump's faceless conspiracy theories
started to take hold this is a fraud
on the American public so we'll be going
to the U.S Supreme Court Carl yeah
anyway you guys get the picture so
there's a bunch of different stories
here of course there is again the story
that Fox News lies to its audience for
profit now you could say well but David
all of these for-profit media networks
are going to create content that is
profitable yes but they don't all
brazenly lie while behind the scenes the
anchors are saying we are telling lies
to our audience there is actually a
difference there there are many
criticisms of corporate media that can
be made that apply to all of these
Outlets but this sort of brazen lying
was not being carried out uh by every uh
corporate media Outlet so that's that's
one story The Second Story of course is
that
Fox News presents itself as news
but the people I just named Hannity
Ingram Tucker Carlson when the rubber
meets the road and they end up in court
universally Fox News lawyers say these
are not news people these are
entertainers who use Hyperbole and
exaggeration and that's the argument
they make when they are confronted with
the reality of their lives but there is
a third story here and it's about the
Congressional hearings that are going on
we talked about last week and the week
before the weaponization of government
hearing we talked about the big Tech
hearings Etc part of their story let me
be clear not Fox News part of the story
from the right has been that media was
biased in suppressing news of the fraud
and irregularities the hunter Biden
story criticism of liberals Etc this is
part of the story that they're telling
what those hearings to some degree are
trying to do
is to retrospectively
legitimize and sort of rehabilitate what
networks like Fox News did
to
um uh come down against Twitter for
example for limiting the spread of
certain disinformation rather than
saying hey you know what Fox News hosts
knew they were spreading lies they want
to use the hearings to say forget about
the text messages the Fox News people
and everybody on the right thought they
were telling the truth and it was big
Tech and whoever else that censored that
truth even though privately we know that
they know that they were telling lies so
we will see what the outcome is from
this lawsuit it is a very big deal and
um I will let you know as that happens
but humiliating if you have a sense of
Shame
it's not clear that the Fox News hosts
do
every day we see more and more stories
about what tech companies and isps are
doing with your data Facebook just
settled a huge lawsuit alleging they
gave millions of users data to a company
helping the Trump campaign everyone
should be using a VPN every time they
connect to the internet no excuses a VPN
hides your IP address it can keep your
data private from these companies and
even from hackers that's why I reached
out to private internet access about
being our sponsor private internet
access is the only VPN that has proven
in court multiple times they don't log
your browsing history their no log
practices are also independently audited
by Deloitte no other VPN takes your
privacy this seriously lightning fast
for downloads streaming content only
available in other countries works as
well works with all major streaming
platforms with one account you can use
it on up to 10 devices and they have a
30 day money back guarantee and their 24
7 support is amazing go to Pia
vpn.com
Pacman to get 83 off that's two dollars
and three cents a month and you'll get
four months free the link is down below